army recruitment commercials give you an
insight the early into the discipline
the loyalty and indie Fitness required
to make it into the US Army but a recent
studies found that the standard appeared
to be slipping in the recruitment pool
one third of American youth it seems
wouldn't be fit enough to be accepted
into the military because they have
their obesity an unhealthy lifestyles so
the Army is warning anyone who wants to
enlist to get fit this is how they're
doing it let me tell you in a bit more
detail most of his common sense doesn't
me said the US Army is pushing some
fundamental changes these Marines have
already seen a revamp to mealtimes with
healthier food being served up over the
next two years the Army's also pledged
to refine its fitness standards make
those tests tougher furthermore in order
to get recruits physically fit
beforehand they're going young they're
promoting Fitness education in schools
and even starting programs to provide
poor families with healthy food as well
good idea
US defense analyst Ivan Ellen gave us
some more suggestions about what else
might help in the United States of
course the military is just a very small
portion of the population and the the
president the government can't tell
people what to eat so the army can
sponsor health programs or whatever with
it but I'm not sure that that's really
going to help that much I think you
probably need to work on the society
itself as far as you know getting more
exercise eating healthier foods etc and
it's very difficult because there's so
much fun stuff to eat that's not very
good for you here in the United States
you